hello I'm Vikram and I'm a graduate
student at Columbia University
engineer at Microsoft today we are going
to talk about differential privacy and
how to leverage Python's 5db library for
it
uh let's first discuss uh what will be
our agenda uh we will start off with
some key concepts of privacy and the
definitions uh then we will see what are
the risk of handling customer data and
moving on we will see how simple
techniques like anonymizing data won't
work in the real world and can still
breach privacy of data so then we will
come to mathematically defining privacy
uh and move to differential privacy and
how it works under the whole we will
also discuss two key types of
differential privacy and towards the end
we will see how IDP works with the help
of word Snippets uh finally we will
conclude the talk with the fun over the
fund review and a q a session
yeah so what is privacy
so privacy is the ability of an
individual or a group of individuals uh
to secure information about themselves
uh thereby expressing themselves
selectively so it can be said as the
right to control how much information
about you is used process stored or
shared uh and you should not confuse
security with privacy Securities uh that
controls who can access the data while
privacy is when and what type of data
can they access uh you can't have
privacy without security but you can
have security without privacy so that is
the key difference between these two
another there are three main concepts of
a privacy first is identifiability so it
refers to the extent to which an
individual can be identified from a set
of data so if a set of data can be
directly linked to an individual then
that data is known as identifiable
second one is linkability so linking at
least two data records of the user uh
for example if there are two databases
and the name of the user uh of the
customer or user is presented in both
the databases we can uh link those two
database and uh try to and can identify
the individual then that is known as
linkability so it uh yeah and then third
is traceability so traceability refers
to the ability to track the usage of
data over time so including who has
access it when it was accessed and for
what purpose so this means that the
origin and the destination origin
destination and handling of the data can
be traced
so yeah one example of how data can be
uh tagged to users uh browsing the
internet is the concept of cookies so
cookies uh sensitive information like
eight salary gender address Etc can be
attached to cookies and this websites
that have access to these cookies will
have access to your personal data also
now since there is a lot of data we are
talking about and uh with data comes
responsibility of handling it properly
uh so we will quickly discuss some of
the most common attacks uh that are uh
possible with uh customers data so first
is information leakage uh it's the
unauthorized access to customer data
that can according to security
vulnerabilities in the machine learning
model or related infrastructure or due
to some Insider threads uh one example
of this can be unauthorized transfer of
data from an external comp from a
computer or network to an external
location another example can be uh there
are some type of timing attacks uh which
exploit the timing differences in a
systems response to different inputs or
events so by analyzing the time it takes
for a system to respond to certain
inputs and attacker can infer
information about the system state or
configuration
uh second is Snapshot attack uh so it's
like attack against access to the model
at a specific point in time Often by
taking a snapshot of the model State and
uses and then uses their information to
launch and launch an attack and the
attack can be used to extract sensitive
information with the model or manipulate
Its Behavior
thirdly it's a membership in front of
that which is in which attacker tries to
determine if a specific customer's data
was used to train a particular model by
exploiting the model's output
and then there is adversarial attacks uh
which involve intentional manipulating
of the input data to cause a machine
learning model to make incorrect
predictions which can potentially reveal
sensitive information about the model or
the data that it is trained on
and then there is model stealing model
stealing uh involves
stealing a machine learning model by
training their own model to mimic it so
they try to mimic the original model and
then uh
they can potentially reveal customer
data using it
and lastly it's model poisoning so in
this uh attackers index malicious data
into the training data set to manipulate
the model's Behavior or to compromise
its accuracy
so uh yeah now you might be thinking
that why don't we simply anonymize the
attributes that we don't want to expose
uh like the private attributes of a user
or customers so we will see with the
help of a case study why it won't work
uh consider a hospital maintaining data
sets of its patients and uh and the data
set has these attributes so for each
patient all these attributes are stored
in that data set uh let's assume that we
have a redacted name and assassin which
are like private to each each patient to
anonymize the data set
now there is a possibility that uh from
the publicly available data sets uh
there might be some data set with common
information for example consider uh
voters list data set is also there
it has these attributes
um and you will see that zip birth date
and tricks are the common attributes in
both these data sets
um
a unique combination of these can be
used to identify an individual uh like
so this is known as the linkability with
which we discuss as one of the key
concepts of privacy that we are linking
to the different databases to find uh
find information about a particular
individual this was in fact a true
incident that happened in which a state
Governor of U.S personal data was leaked
uh with the help of uh these three com
these three attributes uh because like
his zip birth date and sex was the only
uh combination was the only unique
combination uh the existing in both the
data sets and a similar case happened uh
in during Matrix competition of uh
building a predictive model based on
user rating data so they detected the
sensitive information of uh users like
millim and other fields uh but uh they
uh linked it the link their current data
sets with IMDB's data set which is a
publicly available data set and through
that they were able to identify uh what
rating users gave on a particular show
a movie and thus licking their personal
information
yeah so in conclusion uh why don't we
anonymize data so an analyzing certain
Fields uh may make the entire data set
use are useless and not fit for analysis
so it might happen that you are
redacting information which is actually
important for analysis and thus
rendering your model useless second is
uh as we discussed that there might be
related data sets available on uh
available publicly uh and statistically
studying both the data sets and
individual can be easily re-identified
and thirdly if the data set is large the
type of queries that can be drawn from
the data set cannot be predicted so you
can shoot multiple queries on the
database and uh eventually you will be
able to answer the possibility that
eventually you will be able to identify
uh information about an individual
now let me hand it over to Vikram to
discuss about differential privacy
yeah so now let's come to the core topic
of our presentation that is a
differential privacy so to Define it
simply uh basically differential privacy
is a tool which addresses the Paradox of
learning nothing about an individual
while learning information about a
population so as we discussed we should
not be able to learn anything particular
about any particular individual but
would we are still interested in knowing
uh some general Trends out of the
population
so simply put it is a formal
mathematical formulation of the generic
term that we use that is privacy
so just to explain it explain it
properly on the goals and the what the
goal of differential privacy is so
imagine there's a data set in which
which has information about n number of
individuals say Alice Bob and Josh
uh now the what the goal of differential
privacy is uh would be is to make sure
that any kind of statistical analysis on
the database
is possible but it's possible without uh
compromising the privacy of all these
individuals
uh we refer to a query on the database
as any function that I can run over the
database so maybe I can find out okay
what's the main age of all the people in
the database so this is a form of a
query or a function
and
what my aim with the Privacy thing is
that the query output like the output of
the query should be indistinguishable
between this database and an adjacent
database so I'll I'll shortly explain
what an adjacent database is but uh
simply put it's a database which is very
similar to this database but it differs
in like just one field I'll explain this
uh in further detail later on
so basically we'll discuss now what's
under the hood so imagine again again
imagine we have a database containing uh
data of all a lot of people and then we
have an algorithm which does any sort of
statistic and Analysis on this database
uh now what I can do is basically
I can take out the information of any
one particular individual of this data
from this database
so now I I have two databases one with
all the people another one with one less
person
uh and then I can run the same sort of
statistic and Analysis on both of these
databases both of these queries would
result into like each each variable
result in an output and then if an
adversary is able to distinguish between
these two outputs because there is
significant difference in the output
values for example then
then basically the adversary is
successful in knowing some particular
information about that intervention so
uh just for the sake of example let's
imagine this is a cancer data set in
which uh in which the database stores
okay if a person smokes
uh does he or she have cancer
so if in the original data State data
set there are people who have who smoke
and have cancer and my algorithm is
trying to predict whether smoking causes
cancer
uh now what I can do is I can take any
one particular individual remove it and
my query could be okay tell me the
number of people that smoke and have
cancer so imagine the original data set
data set gave the value 100 and now I
remove one particular individual and now
the data set gave me a value 99. so
technically I know that the person whom
I removed smokes and has cancer so this
is kind of leaking is Medical Data his
or her medical data to the public and an
adversary without having access direct
access to the database can still perform
two different queries and know about
know any particular information about a
particular individual so this is exactly
what differential privacy is trying to
prevent and we have some mechanisms in
place for this
so now let's mathematically Define
differential privacy
uh so the definition goes like this for
all pairs of data sets D and D Prime
that differ in a single participant
so D and D Prime here are the adjacent
databases that I talked about uh so we
have these two databases and a training
algorithm M so we call this algorithm M
to be Epsilon Delta differentially
private if for all S and S is the range
of M that is all possible output values
of M
uh if the following equation is true and
the equation is that the probability
that a particular query
a particular queries result uh on on
data set d
is less than or equal to e raised to
power Epsilon of the probability that
the same query on the adjacent database
that is D Prime also results in the in
the range set and there's a additional
parameter called as Delta uh we can
discuss this uh discuss the value of
delta later or what this stands for but
Loosely what what this means is that the
probability that I run a query on on
database d
is the value is similar or very close to
the to the value I would get when I run
the same query on a Json database that
is D Prime
and delt the parametric parameter Delta
basically allows for some error in this
because this is a fairly strict
condition
now these values the values of Epsilon
and Delta are kind of hyper parameters
to my model and I can decide them based
on the basis of how much privacy I want
or how much strict my privacy
constraints are uh so again let's go uh
one by one so Epsilon basically Epsilon
the parameter Epsilon basically limits
on how much privacy is the individual
comfortable about uh Delta is the
probability of actually leaking the
information
so there are cases in which we Define
Epsilon differentially private
algorithms in which the value of delta
is zero uh
and there are cases in which Delta is
non-zero in which in which case we refer
to the general case that is Epsilon
Delta differentially private algorithms
uh as we discussed m is any randomized
algorithm that is uh it does a query on
the database but also add adds some
noise so that uh the outputs are
indistinguishable and S is basically all
the range space of this algorithm or the
image of this algorithm
now uh now let's come to discussing the
two different approaches to differential
privacy
um
basically what we know till now is that
our differentially private any
differentially private algorithm runs
some sort of queries on the data query
on the database and uh so we have some
sort of statistic but on top of the
statistic we add some noise so as to
preserve the privacy of the individuals
in the datums so
there are there are two places where
basically we can add this this noise one
leads to a concept called as local
differential privacy the other is global
differential privacy in local
differential privacy what we do is we
aggregate the data but before
aggregating all the user data or any
sort of data we add noise to the
individual level so each individual
record is manipulated by adding some
noise and then it is stored in a central
database
in this case we we can call the data set
or the database as an untrusted
aggregator because we're not giving the
true information but we are tampering or
enhancing the information by adding some
noise
the second approach is called the global
differential privacy and in in which
case
the aggregator itself is trusted because
it has the original data of all the
individuals
uh but when a third party queries the
data
uh the output of the query from the from
the trusted aggregator is manipulated by
adding some noise so that uh again the
third party is always untrusted but uh
the database itself can be either
trusted or untrusted depending on what
approach we do so
are usually Global differential privacy
results uh and slightly better
performance but however the the strict
requirement for Global differential
privacy is that the aggregator be
trusted so uh because we are giving
supplying true information to the
aggregator
uh now let's come to Pi DP and the
different sort of algorithms and
mechanisms that exist within Pi DP so as
satika mentioned Pi DP is
uh differentially private Library
implementation in Python and it has some
algorithms which are frequently used in
the code Snippets and they'll be also
used in the code Snippets which we will
show later on so as the name suggests
these algorithms uh for example say
bounded mean or bounded sum so these
algorithms are trying to find out some
statistic of the data set but doing
doing those statistics in a
differentially private manner
so take for example bounded sum so this
algorithm is basically trying to sum up
a particular numerical value in the
database but trying to do it in a
differentially private manner that is by
adding some noise and the way in which
we add this noise is referred to as a
mechanism and there are three mechanisms
in place that is the laplacian
exponential and gaussian
so
to explain this with the help of say the
gaussian gaussian mechanism what we do
is there is a database there's an
algorithm so this algorithm tries to
extract some particular statistics from
the database
so
this is where the list of algorithms we
have is utilized and then there's the
second the second parameter is the noise
mechanism so noise mechanism is adding
some numerical noise to the database but
this is not just a random noise this
numerical value is picked from some
distribution and in this case we have
three available distributions that is
laplacian exponential in gaussian and we
add this noise and then we get in out
get the output so uh now all these
mechanisms ensure that there is
differential privacy maintained in our
database and so each of these
distributions would have their own
parameters say for gaussian we have the
mean and variance similarly for the
other two distributions also we have
some parameters and we have to adjust
these parameters in such a way so as to
ensure an Epsilon Delta value of the
differential privacy so uh we'll not go
into the details but it's good to know
that there are three different kinds of
noise we can add to achieve our
differential privacy budget
okay
now let's get to the exciting part of
actually going into the code of Pi DP
and understanding how it works and how a
typical how a typical algorithm which Pi
DP looks like so you might notice the
first couple of statements are just
importing uh the necessary packages the
first is where we import pi dtsdp and
then we also need pandas uh to create a
data set and process it in the
appropriate format so here we are
working with a staggery's data set for
example in which we have some
individuals with their names and
salaries and obviously it's a sensitive
information so the aim is to do some
statistical analysis without leaking any
particular information about the salary
of any individual
um so the next few lines are basically
where we Define the Epsilon and Delta
values as we discussed these values are
just uh like they have not picked this
values based on some analysis these are
they have used random values for now
just to demonstrate uh and now you might
notice that we also have some imports
for example this so what we did is
there's a there's a sub module called
laplacian from which we have imported
two algorithms called bounded sum and
bounded mean which we discussed in the
previous slide so uh simply put what
we're trying to do is the bounded sum
from the laplacian sub module is trying
to find the sum wherein the noise is of
the formulation similarly mean is also
trying to find the mean but adding a
laplacian noise on top of that uh now
how we how we use this is as spoilers
we first Define an object of the bounded
mean and bounded some algorithm and in
as parameters we pass the Epsilon and
Delta values and then to actually
compute and add the noise and give us
back the result we do a DP sum.wix sum
and DP main dot sorry DP sum.quickresult
and dpmain.quick result so this quick
result is basically
whatever algorithm we are using uh it
adds the noise to it of whatever form
that we have reported and then gives us
back the result so in this case I know
the data sum and noisy data mean would
be the true sum and true mean and on top
of that we've added laplacian noise so
as to hide the sensitive information now
uh how is this useful uh it's useful
because
because of the noise it's not possible
for me to basically eliminate for
example Ross from the database take the
sum add add back Ros to the database
take the sum and take the difference but
which would have given me the true
salary of Ross but now because because
of the noise it's impossible for me to
know what the exact value of Ross's
salary is uh and this is basically how
we added some laplacian noise similarly
you you can imagine we can add a
different sort of noise on uh in this
database to get are bounded sum and
bounded mean
now let's move to a slightly complex
example ironically we have used the
knife base algorithm uh as an example of
the complex algorithm
for folks who are experiencing machine
learning might recognize that this this
and this code snippet is
exactly like the SK learn implementation
of using knightways additionally what
we're trying to do is uh we will go from
the top first we import the gaussian
knife phase algorithm from the ml sub
module of Pi DP
and you have a bunch of epsilons ranging
from 0.01
0.001 to 10 and then what we're trying
to do is for all these values of Epsilon
so we're trying to run
uh Knight base algorithm on a set of
data data sets
so for each data set and for each value
of Epsilon we're trying to record what's
the main training accuracy and what's
the mean testing accuracy
and the way we utilize uh these
algorithms is exactly how the standard
implementation of uh gaussian name byz
algorithm uh you would have you would
have done by using the SQL
implementation the additional parameter
that we pass here is the value of
Epsilon that we're trying to use
and then the CLS is uh like basically
what we all we do is to fit and test our
data on the CLS object that we get
bypassing the Epsilon parameter to the
uh to the algorithm and the rest of the
thing is exactly as same uh we we append
or the training accuracy and the testing
accuracy to our Global array and then we
do
and then we do basically uh the main
training accuracy and Main testing
accuracy of these values
so Pi DP the bottom line is that Pi DP
comes packaged with algorithms such as
the Knight base algorithm and uh and the
way this works is by doing exactly what
the name base algorithm does but in a
differentially private manner
uh now let's turn our attention to some
of the things that we should consider
while implementing uh differentially
private algorithms
the first one is using differential
privacy when it's not necessary so it is
not applicable to every problem that is
every problem does not demand the need
of differential privacy for example uh
individual level analysis so imagine a
bank is trying to find out whether a
particular a particular person's bank
activity is fraudulent or not
so in this case the back Bank actually
has the interest of knowing the exact
activity that a particular individual is
doing so in this case differential
privacy would not be the right solution
because we actually want to do uh
individual level analysis uh the second
the second case is when the data set is
so small that
differential privacy is not a right
solution for any sort of analysis to be
done on the small data uh the next point
is no Epsilon is one size fits all that
is uh the value of Epsilon is dependent
upon the kind of analysis that you do on
the database and no one to one value of
Epsilon would be applicable to uh n
numbered end different number of data
sets that we have so
we have to do some analysis before
fixing the Epsilon value the third point
is not understanding the sensitivity of
your data so sensitivity refers to how
much the output of a particular query in
a database changes uh with varying input
uh by not understanding the sensitivity
of your data you might not be adding
enough noise to the query result or the
algorithm might not be adding enough
noise so as to protect the privacy or to
meet the Privacy constraints of uh of
the differential private algorithm
the next point is choosing the wrong
differentially private algorithm so uh
there are multiple differentially
private algorithms in place and
then there's a choice you also need to
invest time in understanding which is
the right algorithm uh for for your data
sets and for your needs
uh the last one is failing to properly
evaluate the accuracy of a result so as
we know differential privacy adds Some
Noise to our data set so it's natural
that the accuracy of your results might
decrease
that a differentially private mechanism
and uh so whenever you do any
differential private algorithm you must
also consider the fact that this can
affect the accuracy of your results
[Applause]
hello thank you a lot for your talk we
do have a couple of questions in a
slider in like a three minutes left
um can you hear me well
well actually we have a plenty of
questions so we will start with the
first one how do you ensure that the
additional noise doesn't alter the
output of the model
yeah
I can take this yeah
uh so yeah while uh we different one
goal of differential privacy is that we
do alter the outputs uh in some way that
is like we cannot query individual data
sets and get to know the exact
information uh but to ensure that are
still analysis and all kind of
algorithms work as they are expected to
do we add it in a mathematical way so in
the video we saw one of the way is
adding laplacian or gaussian noise uh so
we can mathematically prove that adding
noise from these distribution does not
alter the output in such a way that our
analysis is different but it still
offers privacy so uh the the short
version of the answer is that we add it
in a specific way and we just don't add
random noise
another question
um well would it be possible to infer
the distribution of the added noise and
thus the True Value when executing the
same DP query multiple times
uh yeah the same as vikraman said the
previous question uh those uh noise like
LaPlace here and gaussian noise they are
designed in such a way that it's it
becomes a bit difficult to track them
back even if we execute the same query
multiple times so
yeah that is how we are able to preserve
privacy with those uh algorithms
and I think I have the last question
there's more in the slider if you want
to dress in our Discord but for now do
time one more how do DP and K anonymity
differ with regard to the result of not
learning about an individual and do you
see scenarios where this complement each
other
so
yeah welcome do you want to go or should
I it's like yeah okay so uh so basically
anonymity and differential privacy they
both are important techniques for data
privacy but differential privacy is a
bit more uh Advanced technique uh in K
anonymity we basically group individuals
uh which are similar and then we
suppress their attributes uh to make uh
them like to execute them and not leak
information about them but in
differential privacy we add noise uh to
specifically uh like prevent uh data
data leak of users so it's a bit
Advanced technique anonymity but yeah
both are useful techniques uh in this
domain
um oh so sad there's three questions
more but due to time where about when is
uh does anyone really want me to ask
okay there's a lot of people so I will
ask one more uh do you preserve the mean
important information by adding noise do
you perform random operations that could
be used to track single entries back
uh yeah I can take this so uh so the
idea is like when we add sufficiently
large number of individuals and there's
a lot of individuals in our data set the
adding of noise it's expected that the
added noise cancels out and uh while
like to address it like more uh
concretely it's not random noise it's
mathematic like it's a bit it's not a
mathematical distribution uh so again it
comes back to our first question because
we add noise scientifically it uh
basically that is all the Crux of
differential privacy it comes from so uh
yeah but basically the large amount of
noise cancels out but it still preserves
the privacy of the individuals
thank you so much for the talk and
friends and all the questions and thank
you everyone who attended
thank you